congratulations times to because you're
having one of the coolest 2023 is ever
because two exceptional performances
that are so wildly different no it's
very I mean really a privilege as an
actor to get to very contrasting parts
so close to each other it's very lovely
making the most of it I'll start there
actually when you tackle a role can you
tell me something that stays consistent
no matter the movie no matter the genre
but then also maybe something you did to
prep for saltburn that was a first time
thing for you that you've never done
before yeah I think music is always a
consistent um I think I always use music
to just to like ground me in the part or
ground me in the mood around me in the
space no not it comes and goes depending
on the on the scene or the character but
it was a huge thing for salurn Emerald
is quite is well known for making
playlist for us and you know I I made a
playlist for Farley I made a playlist
for Emerald um of just like of like a
thing that I felt like felt like the
world um and and so that is something
that I always really enjoy um but I
think a first on this one on saltburn um
was because it influenced the character
so much was a real specificity with the
clothes um and that was you know I
always try to have a an input but for
the the most part I you know let the
very talented costume designers shine
and do their thing but it really felt
like like something I really wanted to
be a part of and it was a true
collaboration and it took us a second to
really find it but there was you know
there were moments where I was like no
this isn't him this isn't him this isn't
him and when we found it you know it
really allowed fary to come alive one of
the things I really knew he had to wear
where these well I just I was so sure
that he needed to wear Gucci loafers I
said it from day one I was like I really
see him in Gucci loers I really see him
in Gucci loafers and we're like well
let's try these let's try these and then
I bought Emerald for her birthday this
book called um eaten by Ian McDonald
it's a photo book and it it's um it's
all these pictures of I say we we all
bought it um and and it's all these
pictures of different um boys from E the
school in their dorm rooms and the only
person of color the only black boy in in
the in in the book who had a real air of
Farley to him he was he had a real kind
of the way he sat the way his room was
decorated everything really felt like
Farley and on his feet was a pair of
Gucci loafers and I showed emerald and I
said I told you he would have Gucci
loers on and she was like get him the
Gucci loafers get him the Gucci loafers
he will if you look on F he always
whether it's with chu bottoms whether
it's wearing he's running outside he
always got guc love for some iconic
looks across the board in this movie and
I love it so much so you talk about the
uh the costume and the effect that that
can have what about just in terms of
like you personally figuring out just
like physically how he stands how he
carries himself to reflect what he wants
and also how he feels in saltburn Emil
gave me a really lovely note day one in
the camera test as we were just like
working out lighting she said just she
said try she said stand with your feet
touching legs together um and and see
how that feels and because I was kind of
you know there's a real kind of as he
there's like a real relaxed nature to
him he's always he's always almost like
a panther or something he's always like
kind of on the on the not on the prow
but on the alert he's always assessing
he's always watching he's always kind of
working out his next move or like you
know what's going on and so there was
something in my physicality initially
that that sat more with that and he said
she said can I see what it looks like
really upright legs together feet
together almost stood to attention and
then that as soon as she gave that note
it gave it really unlocked something for
me where I just thought oh yes like
this is it he's always on hyper alert
he's always on hyper alert because he's
always ready to he's always ready to
change tactic to change to either make a
joke or to stay silent or to whatever it
is he's like always ready for it and so
that helped but when I found unlocked
that kind of when I was giv that note
and I unlocked that physicality
physicality the character really was
born out of that it was really fun good
note dude's got no choice he has to be
on high alert 247 in that place I love
truly so to dig into him and his
qualities a little more when you first
signed on what quality of Farley were
you most looking forward to Bringing to
life on screen but then also is there
anything that emerged along the way that
wound up being more creatively
fulfilling to play with than you ever
could have imagined at the start totally
um I was really you know I was really
sure you don't ever want someone just to
be and I don't think he is like mean
there was a lot of there was a lot of of
lines that I was like oh this guy is
like you know he's got he's quick he's
sharp tonged and he's and he could be
catty and and you know you try and work
out where does that come from and so it
was really fun to really unpack what
each of those different things are doing
in the moment like why why does he say
that in that moment why does he like for
example the the you know the that first
the very first scene you see Farley he
walks past um Oliver and he says oh nice
jacket and it's so throwaway but it's
not about being mean to Oliver it's
about making everybody else laugh
because it's it's it's it's about self
because then he gets to the English
class and he doesn't even remember who
Oliver is he then says oh hey nice to
meet you and and and it's nothing to do
with him and when he picks apart his
essay he says oh thus that's not about
that's not about him trying to be mean
he's genuinely he comes from a world of
boarding schools where debate like that
is is what you do and the fact that he
doesn't want to G and play and play
sport with him then gets in the wrong
way because he flips it and it's like it
is all about it was it was really trying
to make sure I knew I knew what each
thing was and it wasn't just him being
mean him being a bully because I didn't
think he was I didn't think I I and and
that was really fun but a lot of these
Dynamics a really great thing that
Emerald does is she does the read
through and then she listens rehearses
and then rewrites the script depending
on what has come out of those rehearsals
and so so many new things were born from
that I mean the what ended up being
quite like
uh the dynamic between Farley and Oliver
initially felt a way more
antagonistic and and and there was there
were moments that I felt quite you know
as we get to that karaoke scene on the
couch where they're almost like nose to
nose and you have no idea what's going
to happen and that that kind of came out
of that rehearsal where we were like
hold on there's there's a Vibe switch
here like there is really A vibe switch
here and so some of those new lines came
some of those initial lines came later
like it and and then you know the scene
with with them two in the in the bed
that wasn't in the script initially that
was born later like there's a lot of
these things that like came out of being
like Oh we have to go there because that
is already that that we're already we're
already playing with it so why don't we
just go there there's a few of those
things in the script where we just
really pushed it there was this the
scene with with Farley and then as that
kind of relationship grew the scene with
Farley is he comes back um at the mid
summer night dream party that scene
wasn't in the script initially you know
that scene actually kind of came
probably a week before we shot it and
and I'm sure Emerald was like working on
it for a long time before that but it
was it was so needed it was so needed
for Farley to kind of gratify himself
and say his peace the thing that he'd
been holding on to with these scornful
looks the entire film he just needed to
get it out of him and Purge himself with
it um the most fun collaborative
experience I've ever had so great good
on her for being open to seizing those
opportunities but that switch that
happens between those two characters
makes it one like it's almost like a
sneak attack one of the most rich uh
relationships in the entire film that
goes to places you never would expect in
the beginning totally totally she's a
genius all right I want to touch on some
of your co-stars here before I have to
let you go so you are right smack in the
middle of an exceptional Ensemble so in
in an effort to highlight two people
here of everyone in this cast who were
you most in sync with where the way you
like to work was somewhat similar and
the second you hit set you're like we
get each other but then I kind of want
the opposite someone with a different
approach to the work that challenge you
to adapt and maybe try something new and
for the better that's a lovely question
um I loved the way Rosman worked um and
and and I won't be lazy but but she kind
of encapsulated both of those answers
cuz I lo I loved she was in charact
something I'd never done before she was
in character 5 minutes before we called
called action and so she was just
improvising lines as eleth and it really
and I we jumped straight into it there
was not a moment of me going oh this is
weird let me tried this I just was like
oh yeah and and then farle just came out
and we were just and and then you just
she just said oh God do you remember
that thing when when we did this and
then and and i' look at her the first
time she did it I remember saying sorry
and she she said f darling I'm just and
then we were all of a sudden just
improvising and then she called you know
um emal would call Action and we'd be
straight into the scene talking about
something else and then the lines would
start and it just it made the world so
rich and me and it it wasn't something
I'd done before but it immediately was a
kind of thing you do in your head and it
takes someone as experience and
confidence as rosand to be to to just do
it and and remind you oh it's okay to do
it because this is the work and we're
having fun and we're playing and we're
finding these things and that comes with
experience and time and you know and
having a true sense of self as rosin has
and and that is something that I I hope
I can take forward with me um in in
other things it was so it was so
brilliant and so fun and so gratifying
um Barry I guess sometimes was
challenging be in in the best ways
possible because you you don't often
Emerald call Emerald says he has Shark
eyes but you don't know what he's
thinking you don't know what he is
thinking you don't know what he's going
to do and that was unbelievably exciting
in a scene because it meant you were
constantly on high alert you were
constantly alive and you neither of you
knew what was going to happen and it
made something unbelievably electric
he's a very he's a very present electric
actor because he doesn't know what he's
going to do before he gets in and and
and that's he's he's really in the
moment in that way and I like to kind of
you know I'm not necessarily like
prepared I know how I'm going to say the
thing by any means but you know I've got
like a maybe I've got a sense of where
the scene's moving etc etc but maybe it
moved somewhere completely else in the
scene with Barry and I loved that I
loved the excitement of that I love the
challenge of it and it was it was it was
so fun and I think it really makes it
really makes some of the scenes in the
film come alive in in such a rich way
spot on description I think Jacob used
the word electrifying actually earlier
and I'm like yeah I get it I feel it
it's perfect for this role really you're
all exceptional this is one of my
favorite Ensemble pieces of the whole
damn year so congratulations I
appreciate it thank you so
much